it sounds to me like you respectfully
are struggling with a little self-doubt
where you're saying that maybe if not
for affirmative action you may not have
made it to this school and that's sad to
me because I believe that if we take
someone with fewer resources like
yourself who made her resume sing and
dance and was a brilliant student and we
gave you more resources I believe you
were brilliant with little and I believe
that you would be brilliant with more I
think for you to think of yourself that
only because of a government program you
got into this great school it's kind of
sad as opposed to relating it to your
accomplishments seems to me that
actually affirmative action which would
view you through the prism of race
rather than your accomplishments
would be self-defeating
I guess if you put it that way it would
be